c'est l'esprit de la marque une vie à ce
que je vais gagner les 100 euros puisque
j'ai annoncé il y avait la star du
moment avec nous en face time quand je
vous dis la star du moment c'est la star
du moment
non mais vous allez voir qu'il s'agit
qui décide qui s'abat ici tout le monde
considère que c'est la star du moment et
vous aussi parmi vous gagnez bien où je
gagne 100 euros soyez gentil faut qu'on
le décide
tu me fais bien pour il faut que vous le
décide un pc si on ne décide pas bah si
on décide quoi on a perdu alors là vous
allez voir vous inquiétez pas de sens je
gagne c'est moi qui avais décidé vous en
perdez pas une image
je voudrais une image regardez permettez
moi l'image de ce qui s'est passé
dimanche
regarde
c
je suis pas né mon sens via la france de
nouveaux bilans les enfants mineurs
il a remporté le grand prix de monza
ça faisait bannière daniel 24
et bien sachez on a le patient des
hôtels formule 1 et non regardez qui est
avec nous qu'a voulu dire à mots pierre
diot
[Applaudissements]
merci d'être avec nous je franchement tu
nous a fait vibrer c'est énorme ce que
tu as fait non merci
en 10 54 hockey en france
elle avait gagné un grand prix donc
beaucoup d'émotion et pierre est-ce que
avant le début du grand prix
tu t'es dit à un instant est un instant
ce que tu dis ce soir je serai le
vainqueur du grand prix de monza où
est-ce que même pour toi tu croyais pas
non honnêtement
honnêtement non le matin forcément faire
la meilleure course possible mais non ça
faisait en 15 ans dans mon écurie dont
une seule victoire en 15 ans donc c'est
pas quelque chose on peut répéter tous
les week-ends toutes les courses mais
avec les circonstances de la course au
deuxième départ d'un enfant d'un
position sur la grille pierre jeux de
suite plus longtemps et je sais que pour
toi ça a été une énorme revanche en plus
cette victoire parce que chez voilà ce
qui s'est passé en 2010 neuf états du
voile a changé d'écurie a été rétrogradé
de red bull chez toro rosso lors de la
trêve estivale et pour moi c'est jaime
ton caractère
j'aime vraiment à force de caractère
keira mentale et de fou et je pense
qu'en formule 1 voilà le ça ça joue à
80% dans la ville et sa simplicité
ah ouais t'as simplicité pierre je veux
dire que je suis très fan de toi est
vraiment voilà je voulais dire que
j'étais très heureux de te voir ce soir
est ce que tu nous as apporté comme
émotion dimanche voilà ça nous fait du
bien en ce moment où ça veut dire si
grand
[Applaudissements]
alors prtt où la foule en ce moment là
t'es où c'est sans mauvais là par hasard
là je suis à milan donc à milan la
prochaine course à dos dames ils ont là
est-ce que tu pour passe à paris bientôt
j'espère j'espère passer à paris bientôt
j'ai beaucoup de famille ben normandie
je vous donne match up à paris
tu penses tu pas toi est ce que tu peux
voir de la mozzarella
je sais que tu as maté
je sais que tu as raté l'appel du
président emmanuel macron est ce que tu
as pu la voir derrière ou pas encore
rappelé je pense est très occupé bien
plus que bien plus que moi et non
malheureusement n'a pas répondu
c'est un message très émouvant et qui
ment c'est une grande surprise et ben
pierre et j'espère qu'il va bientôt
venir
et tu sais pour avoir un nouvel appel du
président tu sais ce qu'il te reste à
faire je garde le prochain grand prix
voilà il était tranquille pire je te
souhaite beaucoup de chance et bravo
pour ce que tu t'es bravo pour ton
mental
aujourd'hui on est fier d'avoir un
champion champion en france bravo pierre
gasly kate avec tous nous a fait
l'honneur d'être à des coûts
[Musique]
kouchner
monza et les 100 euros on va en parler
dans un instant d ela alors allez c'est
mon cachet pour quatre émissions 50 et
50 m à écouter les offres publiques
donner à ma chérie et thierry
[Applaudissements]
j'espère que patrice laffont rentrera
départ également pour le public